hello and welcome I'm James Murphy and today
we're taking a look at a subtle rule that
python has about variable scopes. let's
play a game. what does the function print?
let's start with an easy one, shout out the
answers as we go. tell me either what it's
going to print or what error it's going to give.
let's start with f what do you think happens when
we run it? well of course when we run it we
get an error, specifically a name error. okay
the first one was really easy what about the
second one, g. is it any different from f?
well of course we still get an error, but it's
actually a different error. now, technically,
unbound local error derives from name error, but
I think it might be surprising to many of you
that something different happened at all. somehow
python knew that I was going to assign to x later
in the function. normally in python, outside of a
looping context, we don't expect statements in a
function that are later in the function to affect
statements that are earlier in the function.
it turns out that whether or not a
variable like x is determined to be a
free variable or a local variable is actually
determined at compile time, not at runtime.
in the function f, there are no assignments
to the variable x so x is determined to be a
free variable. that means when we say print x it
tries to look up x in the global scope and fails.
in g, however, the function does contain an
assignment for x, it says x equals 1. so that
means that in the function g, x is determined to
be a local variable. that means that when we try
to print x it looks it up in the local scope and
hence we get a local error, not a global error.
keeping that in mind, let's look at another
two examples and see if you get them right.
what do you think happens when we call h? we
have defined the global variable y equals 0
before defining the function and then we try to
print y in the function. go on just shout it out.
okay this was another easy one, it prints zero.
now what do you think happens for the j function?
take your time, I'll wait. okay have
you locked your guess in? here we go.
when I run the j function, I get another unbound
local error. now you might look at this and say:
when I call j, we have this global variable y
that's defined to be zero, so print y should be
printing 0 just like in the previous case. but
that's not how the variable lookup rules work.
because somewhere in the function j assigns y a
value, everywhere in the function y is treated as
a local variable. that means at the beginning when
we try to print y, it doesn't even try to look
it up in the global scope. it only looks in the
local scope. this can be extra confusing because
this assignment y equals 1 could theoretically
be hundreds of lines later in the function.
this is yet another reason to avoid
using global variables if you can.
I also want to point out that other languages
like c and c++ do not do things this way.
when I run this function it first prints
the global I and then prints the local I,
that's why we get 0 and then 1 down at the bottom
here. I even compile with -Wall and -Wextra to
give me extra warnings and still no warnings to
be seen. if I want to get a warning for this kind
of behavior I have to compile with -Wshadow. the
shadow here is referring to the fact that what I'm
doing is called variable shadowing. if I have a
variable in an inner scope like inside a function
where I define a variable that has the same
name as another variable in an outer scope
like the global scope, then this is called
"variable shadowing". in this case I would
say that this variable i shadows the one
in the global scope. for obvious reasons
you should really try to avoid this if at all
possible. of course the same goes for python,
shadowing variables puts you on the fast track
to writing bugs. in case you were ever wondering,
this is actually one of the reasons why I define
a separate main function rather than just putting
things down here. any assignments that I do
down here are actually in the global scope
and that means there's a chance that they're being
shadowed. I might expect an error if I try to
print y here but because the y down here is in the
global scope I actually just print that y instead.
on the other hand if I define a main function
then any assignments in here that I do are local
to that function. that means anything that I do
in here I don't have to worry about affecting
things in other functions like h. now when I
run the function I get the expected error in h.
that's all I've got on this topic. now that you
know the rules, go back and watch the video again
and let me know if you get them all right this
time. if you like the video, please consider
sharing with your friends, subscribing, and
slapping that like button an odd number of times.